herr krause ich habe sie haben
wahrscheinlich zugehört als ich gerade
die aktuellen nachrichten
vorgetragen habe zu dem gespräch das
ergebnis des gesprächs von scholz und
makro mit putin im prinzip einfach nur
die aufforderung dessen was sie
eigentlich immer gesagt haben was können
solche gespräche noch bewerten ja sie
werden nichts bewirken sofern sich die
militärische lage vor ort nicht
verändert und das einzige worauf wir
hoffen können ist dass die ukraine noch
noch besser sozusagen die russen
abwehren dann könnte ich mir vorstellen
dass auch russland zu verhandlungen
bereit ist natürlich sind die russen zu
verhandlungen bereit aber nur zu
bedingungen die für die ukraine völlig
unakzeptabel sind und ich hoffe dass
sich in moskau eine ernüchternde
einstellung über die bisherigen
militärischen erfolge einstellen aber
woher nehmen sie diese hoffnung ja die
nutzungsraten sind sie unterschiedlich
also ungefähr vier bis fünfmal so viele
russische verluste als die ukraine haben
bei wesentlichen
waffensystemen und die motivation der
ukraine ist auch gewaltig und die russen
haben erhebliche defizite in ihrem kampf
bisher aufgewiesen zum beispiel ist die
luftwaffe nur sehr gering angesetzt
worden und man fragt sich warum das so
war vermutlich liegt es daran dass die
russen doch doch erhebliche probleme
haben grossangelegte
flugmanöver durchzuführen und das sind
defizite strukturelle defizite der
russischen streitkräfte und das ist
natürlich ein plus für die ukraine auf
den punkt würde ich gern noch mal näher
eingehen weil wir uns in der redaktion
hier auch schon gefragt haben mit
unseren
militärexperten wagen wird die luftwaffe
offenbar nicht in dem ausmaß eingesetzt
wie man es erwartet hätte kann das auch
mit den auch deutschen waffenlieferungen
beispielsweise von flugabwehrraketen
stinger raketen zusammenhängen man will
eben nicht dass diese flugzeuge
abgeschossen werden und entsprechende
bilder auch produziert werden ja das ist
richtig die luftabwehr möglichkeiten der
ukraine sind sehr groß und es hat ja
schon eine ganze reihe von
abgeschossenen kampfflugzeugen gegeben
besonders erdkampfflugzeuge sind also
solche die relativ dicht am boden
operieren müssen da gibt es auch
beeindruckende bilder auch von
kampfhubschraubern die abgeschossen
worden sind das kann also durchaus ein
faktor sein aber es gibt eine
untersuchung eines britischen instituts
die eben auch zu dem schluss kommt dass
die
die möglichkeiten der russischen piloten
genügend zu trainieren oder zu fliegen
doch nicht sehr groß gewesen sind und
möglicherweise meldungen und nach oben
durchgegangen sind dass die
einsatzbereitschaft der russischen
truppen der russischen luftwaffe höher
sei als sie tatsächlich gewesen ist es
kann heute unterschiedliche signale aus
moskau krause einer seite droht russland
mit angriffen auf die westlichen
waffenlieferungen in der ukraine und
waren auch vor einer weiteren stärkung
der nato präsenz im baltikum
gleichzeitig wird aber auch angeboten
grundsätzlich wieder über eine abrüstung
mit den usa zu verhandeln wie passt das
alles zusammen ist es ausdruck der
unsicherheit die dort offenbar in moskau
herrscht nein es ist ausdruck einer an
der völlig überschätzung der
möglichkeiten moskaus die haben wir ja
schon bei dem ultimatum im dezember
vergangenen jahres gesehen moskau hatte
uns allen ein ultimatum gestellt
praktisch die verbindung westeuropa
europas zu den usa aufzugeben und alles
das einzustellen was den russischen
sicherheitsbehörden evo oder genehm ist
und das ist eine ultimative aufforderung
die wir nicht die wir nicht nachkommen
können und russland ist natürlich immer
gerne bereit darüber zu verhandeln wie
wir seinen ultimativ gestellten
forderungen entsprechen können aber wir
müssen mal uns gegenwärtigen will wir
finden uns wieder in einem kalten krieg
mit russland und wenn wir auf die
ukraine schauen denn ist es keinesfalls
mir ein kalter krieg und ich befürchte
dass russland immer noch nicht begriffen
hat dass es sich übernommen hat oder
vielleicht ist dieses zeichen dieser
dieser drogen gegen nato staaten oder
auch gegen finnland und schweden
vielleicht auch schon anzeichen dafür
dass in russland vielleicht nicht mehr
so ganz rational gedacht wird ich weiß
es nicht aber auf jeden fall dieser
feldzug war kein erfolg für russland er
hat ja den resten die einheit des
westens eher noch gestärkt und es könnte
durchaus sein dass länder wie schweden
und finnland entgegen dem bild den
willen der russen jetzt der nato
beitreten aber letzte frage herr krause
das ist ja gerade die sorge dass eben in
moskau nicht mehr rational gedacht wird
viele menschen in deutschland machen
sich auch sorgen als die meldung kam es
glaube ich auch schon zwei wochen her
inzwischen dass die atomaren
streitkräfte in alarmbereitschaft
gesetzt worden war joe biden sprach
heute auch noch mal davon dass alles
versucht werden müsse um einen dritten
weltkrieg zu vermeiden wie hoch sehen
sie diese gefahren ich sehe die gefahr
überhaupt nicht so ich habe das gefühl
dass wir uns hier in eine panische
selbst abschreckung hineinsteigern es
wird wegen dieses wegen der ukraine
keinen kernwaffenkrieg zwischen den usa
und russland geben es hat auch nur eine
gewisse erhöhung der alarmstufe
oder der bereitschaft stufe bei den
russischen strategischen angriffs
kräften gegeben aber wenn sie diese
gegen die usa einsetzen würden würde
russland im nächsten zug zerstört sein
und dann gäbe es helmut ihn und seine
kabarett nicht mehr also insofern wir
müssen mal ein bisschen vorsichtiger
sein mit all diesen ganzen
schreckensszenarien ich sehe auch nicht
dass bei einer militärischen
intervention des westens in der ukraine
nun gleich an weltkrieg ausbricht ich
kann einfach nicht die eskalation ketten
erkennen die dann anspringen würden dann
wir sind nicht mehr im kalten krieg wir
sind ich mir den 80er jahren wo es mit
einer in europa zwei hochgerüstete lager
gab und wo die östliche seite ein
gefährliches
offensives potenzial hatte was natürlich
auch bei kleineren fällen durchaus zu
einem krieg hätte führen können das ist
ja heute alles nicht der fall wir
sollten alles ein bisschen gelassener
und auch ein bisschen wagemutiger sehen
wir lassen uns im augenblick viel zu
sehr von unserer eigenen panik und angst
gleiten ja dennoch sind wir mitten in
europa in einem krieg und ja von
gelassenheit
kann man in der ukraine natürlich nicht
sprechen vielen dank nach nami danke ja
schon